what's going on guys welcome back to
GameSpot's coverage of MLB the show 17 I
am once again here with Ramone Russell
from Sony San Diego and today we're
going to be checking out road to the
show
yes Road to the show pave your path
that's what we're going to be taking a
look at today why don't you take us away
right so um you know Nick Livingston our
game design League and his brother John
Livingston and uh
Compton worked so hard on what's called
what we are calling pave your path and
for road to the show this is a
foundation year I think I've made this
reference a few times but diamond
dynasty this year is like complete it's
like this is where we wanted the moat to
be two three years down the road this is
the foundation year for Road to the show
and we're gonna you're going to see us
make those same strives that we made
with DD in Road to the show and so what
we wanted to do was people had kept on
asking us you know we want some type of
story element to wrote the show like the
off the field stuff is real get great
but we want something else to do and so
we thought about it and what we came up
with up with was pave your path it's a
nonlinear experience the decisions that
you make in the choices that you make in
road to the show this year will alter
your career right so if you create a
centerfielder and you start to make
decisions it will take you down this
road if you start over and make
different decisions it could take you
down a different road and that's what
we're trying to do we're trying to make
a narrative where your decisions matter
and it takes you down these different
roads and we had some help with this as
well you know we always try to listen to
the community and we have Skype calls
with our community we ask them what they
like to see we also talk to some minor
leaguers and you know some rookies from
last year about what their experiences
were in the minor leagues because you
know baseball is really unique in the
fact that when you get drafted you don't
start up the MLB I mean even if you're
you know a Bryce Harper or Stephen
Strasburg
you know a Trey Turner like it really
doesn't happen like everybody goes to
the minor leagues and baseball has that
unique story and you know we picked
those guys brains and he wants to know
like what those experiences were and
there were a few guys that we got to
talk to like Mac Winton from the San
Francisco Giants Derek law on for the
San Francisco Giants both of those guys
are good friends of the studio and trade
turn as well so we talked to some guys
with some first-round picks we talked to
some guys who drafted a little later
later in the rounds and we were able to
pick their brains and they were able to
tell us you know how their stories were
different cuz all those guys had
different stories and you know one of
the ones that sticks out a lot is Trey
Turner's story last year you know he
believed he's a shortstop naturally and
the Nationals wanted him to play
centerfield because you know he was
blocked at shortstop and they told him
that they asked him hey we want you to
play centerfield you it'll get you up to
the show you know what do you think and
he was like you know I'm a team player
of course I'll do that cuz you know I
want to get up to the show but at the
same time it's like you know I'm a
shortstop but he understood that you
know I'm gonna be a team player first
I'm gonna go up here and I'm a ball out
it's in the field and I'm gonna show
them that I I'm multifaceted I can play
multiple positions but at the same time
you know I still want to come back to
shortstop and so we emulated that in the
game this year there will be
opportunities and you'll see it as we
start playing where you're going to get
asked some questions you're going to
have to make some decisions and
depending on the decisions that you make
yeah that's going to take your career on
a different path so here we are we're in
the road show we're in a locker room
scene which is all new you can also see
the social media feed I which is alter
this year so where we are I've been to a
few other places the last few days and
this is the same road to the show so
what's happened right now in this
storyline is I have already been drafted
once by the Angels I said I'm not going
to sign with you and what happened was
the Angels management basically said we
don't even want you so I had to go back
to school and get redrafted so I went
back to school I did the showcase games
again and I turned into a fifth round
draft pick and I've been drafted by the
Chicago White Sox organization
and here we are I'm in lower a ball and
we're going to see what happens so this
is the lowest a this is I believe we're
in Dublin Dublin juror dresses his team
before their season opener for many of
these young men it is their first game
as a professional all right so we just
heard the narrator talk so the way that
we wanted to do our our narrative and
role to the show was it's a documentary
it's a documentary style thing we have a
narrator like you'd hear in a hard
knocks so the narrator will narrate a
specific scenes to basically set things
up and then you know you'll make those
decisions alright so we're going to sim
this game we're going to see them a
bunch of games until we can get to a
basically a splinter point in the
storyline this is what happens so I'm a
sim all the way down here now are these
some people are asking are these real
minor league teams yeah yeah we have
licenses for double-a and triple-a so
all the logos are the minor league cheat
teams that change their names and logos
those have been updated so yeah we do
have all the correct greats the a minor
leaguer is assigned temporarily to a new
role all right so here we go our manager
has just instructed us that he wants us
to play right field for a short time and
this goes back to the Trey Turner
situation I believe we're a shortstop or
a second baseman so I have a few choices
here I can say you know seriously I can
say mind if I ask why oh okay whatever
so for the purposes of this visit right
we're not going to say whatever I'm ago
manifests why always looking to fill
needs clubs we'll explore every way a
prospect might be capable of
contributing all right here we go so in
the managers telling CEO this might help
us down the line to have some
versatility and it'll help your skill
set so you know I'm a third baseman
I could go you know I was brought in
here to be a third baseman but I have no
experience as right fielder or I see so
we're not gonna do that
we're gonna go I'm a third base back
we're gonna go to push back okay and
when team needs collide with the players
expectations a game of dreams also
becomes a game of choices all right here
we go and the managers like no you
didn't come here to be a third base you
came to be a ballplayer so I want you to
do that so here
have some we have even more options I
can keep going hardline I'm a third
baseman I can say it's totally new to me
or I can like you see we keep giving you
opportunities to say hey okay like
you're I'll go down to eat
not even the evil Road it's just a
different choice right and there's no
right or wrong choices there are just
consequences to the choices that you
make so we're going to continue down
this line I'm a third baseman this
player with strong convictions finds out
a team can have convictions - all right
let me see you know you know the
Destroyers that I made had some
consequences then again and pave your
path there's no right or wrong choice
just your choices have consequences so I
chose to stick with my guns say I'm a
third baseman and now I've been bitched
now if we reset this I could make
different choices and another thing will
happen can you in any situation be cut
from the team a recent bench player
received a blow from his representative
all right so I have Isaac Aldous he's
like I just got a call from management
they said you refused to play some some
games his right field or what happened
and I think that's it you know I told
him no that's my position who wants to
see his advisee get back on the playing
field all right I advisors talking to us
again they said they'll return you to
the lineup but you've got to be willing
to give it a go a right fielder just
temporarily so here you know what Nick
and John and Compton are doing they're
giving you an opportunity to basically
change your path they give you an
opportunity to come back so I'm going to
say okay fine I don't like it but
whatever the road to the show is not
always a straight or predictable one all
right here we go and the advisor tell us
maybe it's time we get serious about
finding the sports agents to bring on
board to help you deal with this kind of
thing I'm gonna start looking into that
some more all right so here we go so
we've seen oh we got a trophy so those
are that's kind of a snippet of what's
going to happen with pave your path now
this isn't the only thing we've done
with Road to the show what we've also
done we've talked about this a little
bit is you know we've completely
revamped creative players so it's not
only wrote the show pave your path but
how you guys how your guy looks and in
most those things have an upgrade
- so we're gonna just you can really
customize you guys so I'm gonna go with
some random just going to randomize a
guy so you can see some of the options
here see okay all right got the little
flattop going Oh big fan of the head
okay alright so we're going to keep that
let's keep that see uh finer finds so
what's real crazy is so we did this
thing I think everybody will see it like
next week so our character team is about
six or seven people and it's this team's
jobs to do all of the updates for the
uniforms to take the face scans and to
turn them in the heads they created all
of the new content that you see and
create a player and we had they had this
funny thing to wear during crunch time
they said hey we're not going to shave
at all so nobody shaved and at the end
we basically did a Russian Roulette
where everybody picked different facial
hair styles from the game to cut out so
if you see um you'll probably see Nick
on the stream today and so Nick will
have well well by the time you see this
video yeah by the time you see this
video Nick will have this he has this
and I think he has he has something else
what else the only combo to come
yeah he has a combo because you can you
can stack difference um so a soul patch
and he has the barber we're not gonna
choose that when we're gonna go with the
school at the woodsman let's go that
film in without sticking it's like the
playoff beard only yeah play already
steak so for facial hair sets we've
added 22 new facial hair sets hair
styles we've started from scratch we've
added over 20 new hair styles and you've
seen a few of those as well and then you
can still stacking which is cool do I
want to stack something okay that looks
a little weird let's see you want to
stack anything I think I think I think
we're good I think we're good well we've
also done you can see this is the we
have this Cabbage Patch dolls look to
our creative players hopefully you won't
notice that as much as we did so much
work on the faces skin tones and the
eyeballs we start from scratch if you
saw those comparison shots you could
really tell the difference between our
new eyeballs and how they looked on in
previous years of the game so we really
wanted to make sure
oh that the guy that you created and
wrote the show and in those rosters that
guys create looks so much more like real
players it's been a ton of positive
feedback on the previous video we did
together
a lot of people are saying that they
look like real people that is fantastic
if we're hearing that that means that
means we're doing what we need to do so
we're going to change so we're ready to
play all right so we're going to sim
some more games so we can get another
scene hitting 305 oh that average is
going down it's just it's us going back
up after trying this player out in a new
role his team likes what they've seen
alright so we're back into the manager's
office matters like we like your
potential is right as a right fielder
and the fact is the club has a need at
that position at the major league level
would you think about going forward in
that role and so this is this right here
is this is what wrote the show pave your
path is all about the choice we make
here will have a lasting effect on our
career yep I can say my heart is kind of
set at being a third baseman sir I can
ask what this be permanent or I can do
the Trey Turner thing where I'm like
whatever I can do to help the White Sox
win the world championship so that's
what I that's what I'm going to do I'm
going to make that decision yep the most
direct road to the show is not always
the one that was first envisioned all
right so the managers like well you know
I aim to bring you along as the right
fielder then it doesn't affect your
training focus you can still work to
hone the attributes that you let will
get you where you really want to be down
the line so BAM like like now we're a
right fielder yep so road show pave your
path the decisions that we make it early
on has completely altered our career if
we go back and make different decisions
we'll end up somewhere else yeah and
that's what we think is so special about
the first year the foundation year of
road to the show pave your path so what
is your favorite new feature that's been
attitude the show 17 this year as part
of road to the show uh it's it's
everything I mean the two main ones is
is create a player revamp allowing you
to create much
other looking players we have so many
new hairstyles now we have so many new
facial hair sets from an animation
standpoint you know you could we were
trying to give you more opportunity
there to express yourself so you can
pick a batting stance and a different
homerun sequence which you haven't been
able to do so I could pick Bryce
Harper's batting stance with Jose
Bautista homerun sequence and what that
allows me to do is if my batting stance
in my home run swing will be Jose but I
will be Bryce Harper's right but my
celebrations at first base second base
third base and home plate will be Jose
about Tisa's and every home run sequence
sequence that we have in the game you
can now choose so you can mix and match
those you know sounds of the show comes
back we've doubled sounds of the show so
if you want to upload your own walk-up
music for your gun road to the show you
know you can continue to do that and
with pave your path we're just really
excited that you know this is we're
really going to blow this out over the
next few years like we really want it to
splinter off so we can hear those
different stories about guys telling us
hey I started out as a shortstop but I
ended up as a right fielder like the
ideas that we have moving for are
amazing and so we can't wait for people
to try it out and see what pave your
path is about in its first year I know
we're really excited and I know a lot of
the commentaries and the previous
YouTube videos are going to be really
excited to see everything that the road
to the show has to offer this year again
guys if you've been enjoying GameSpot's
coverage of MLB the show 17 be sure to
hit that subscribe button and my thanks
to Ramon again for coming in thanks for
having all the insights and I will see
you next time see ya martial name email
be to show by station
you